[Music]
okay everyone I am so excited today
because I am joined by Camilo Marone and
tsuki Waterhouse who star in Daisy Jones
and the sixth on Prime video how you
guys doing today
really good really good yeah oh good
yeah you guys I'm so excited to talk to
you guys and people to see this
performance by both you you're both
incredible uh Camila you absolutely chew
up the screen in this is a part that
someone who could have easily overdid it
you got it just right so what is your
biggest philosophy strategy as an
actress if you like that one thing you
really try to do
first of all thank you for that comment
that's very nice of you
um second my one philosophy as an actor
I mean I I do work hard before I get on
set in kind of creating the back story
uh I do all my homework I kind of map
out the Arc of the character before I
get there I work with acting coaches and
then on the day I try to kind of forget
everything I know and be in the moment
and and be present I think that's my
kind of like my formula right now that I
hope is is working uh for me but it's a
thing that kind of makes me feel
prepared but also free at the same time
yeah I love that that's great advice and
yeah it's definitely working so yeah I
mean that's awesome too that you're
prepared and do the notebook and stay
present all good things uh Suki I love
the independence of your character Karen
and how she speaks her mind a lot did
you find yourself agreeing or easily
relating to a lot of what Karen says or
believes in
I think actually I I uh I had when I
when I first took on Karen I think I was
um I think Karen actually I I felt like
I had something to I always look for
what I can overcome in myself and I
think I think through Karen I was able
to you know step into a in into more of
a confidence and a fearlessness that
that I didn't think I actually had
before
um so that that but there were things
that I could connect to and uh that
there were things like to in in our kind
of personalities that I could connect to
I think she I think she's always like
quietly humored I think she's incredibly
independent I think she's able to you
know she she she's kind of she's kind of
uh she's a bit like a puppeteer she's it
she she like her her biggest desire is
to you know have everyone keep you know
keep the band together and keep it
thriving and and uh try and yeah try try
and not
um try and stay out of drama and and get
people in the studio working put
I love that that's one of the best
answer I got to because I love that
point you make about using acting to
overcome something that's really cool uh
Camilo what about your character did you
want to make sure because you have the
pressure of the book readers fans who
love this character would you want to
make sure you just got across the
audience the most anything else with
this character
I think that she's not a Wallflower that
even though she's not in the bend and
you know she's not on stage with them
her presence is essential and her
strength behind the scenes is equally as
important as it is for the people on on
the stage and I think that it's a
character that could be interpreted as
flat or linear or
could have been written that way you
know and kind of go into the stereotypic
typical kind of wife of a rock star
genre and I think that the basis of this
character already came so fleshed out to
me that I just
um rode this this wave of this woman who
is so powerful and in her own body that
I think that's what I want people to
take away from her is that even if
you're not front and center and all the
time it doesn't take away from your
power and your strength yeah great great
answer and I think they will take that
away and I'm excited for people to see
that portrayal of it uh watch Camilla
and Suki crush it in Daisy Jones and the
six on Prime video out now thank you
guys so much for joining us in the
future have a good one thank you so much
foreign